foreign
what is the price of sports watching the
World Cup being Qatar the human cost
migrant workers the daily lives of women
and lgbtq people and the crazy sums of
money thrown at trying to make Qatar
look Progressive not only to benefit its
rulers but also the West in justifying
their business ties
qatar's ruling Emirates spoke of
celebrating diversity as the premier
men's football event kicked off while
officials seized a Brazilian
journalist's home state flag which
happens to feature a rainbow
then FIFA banned the one love armbands
captains were planning on wearing in
protest of qatar's laws against same-sex
relationships
instead Germany's players covered their
mouths for the team photo they received
praise from German Chancellor Olaf
Schultz he said he was happy to see them
send a clear signal in favor of an open
Society
Iran's Squad refused to sing their
Anthem before their Opening match at
least possibly risking their lives back
home where protests rage over the death
of a young woman detained by the
morality police Iranian State TV cut
away from its live broadcast
so divisive and so expensive there's
never been a World Cup like this I'm Ben
fazolin in Berlin with your DW business
special
joining me to Crunch the numbers and
discuss the knock-on effects is David
con investigations correspondent at the
British newspaper the guardian he wrote
a book about corruption at FIFA
football's World governing body David
just first off is there still corruption
at FIFA
um well it's it's very hard to know uh
for sure because the nature of
corruption is obviously that it happens
behind closed doors but I think we do
have to acknowledge that the corruption
scandals led to many of the people at
FIFA being arrested or banned from
football and it is largely a new broom
at FIFA and they have brought in more
modern corporate cultures to try to
address the corruption issues and I
think the general assumption is that
it's much less of a significant feature
than it was before the arrests in 2015.
well the corruption aside qatar's World
Cup is the most expensive edition of the
tournament we'll look at the figures
later first the human costs rights
groups say thousands of workers may have
died on the huge construction sites the
government calls the claims outrageous
and offensive it's threatened to sue uh
let's clear up that issue first of all
with David because a lot of people are
calling this the the world's deadliest
major sporting event in history
yeah and I think it can become quite
distasteful and uncomfortable for there
to be
so many arguments about the figures for
for deaths for people dying but it has
come to that now a lot a lot of people's
cite an article that was written in the
guardian that has a figure of 6500
migrant workers dying
um but that that article seems to have
created the impression in people's minds
that that was 6 500 people dying in the
construction of World Cup stadiums but
the article never said that it said that
it was 6500 migrant workers from five
different
South Asian countries who had died in
Qatar in I think the 10 years since the
World Cup was awarded in in all
different occupations and not related
many many of them I think most of them
to construction
uh are not directly related to World Cup
Construction in which the figures in
that article are that there were 37
workers who died in the construction who
worked on the construction of stadiums
of which three were accidents in the
construction
one of whom was a British construction
worker
and 37 have died in what they call that
non-work related deaths but this is the
big issue for human rights groups not
necessarily related to World Cup
construction is just the Heat and the
stress of the working conditions in the
Gulf in that part of the world not just
in Qatar and the countries have been
built by the labor of workers brought in
from very very poor countries mainly in
South Asia so the human rights groups
issue is that not enough is done to
protect people from from the heat from
the suffocating heat that in many of the
months in the year it's really uh very
very oppressive heat and you do have to
be very careful of people's Health when
they're working there
so the broader issue of of worker
treatment uh what can't be argued is
this is the most expensive Edition by
far the price tag is an unparalleled 220
billion dollars just uh look at the huge
gap here previously the most pricey
World Cups were Brazil 2014 and Russia
2018 which cost less than 15 billion
Germany's 2006 cup cost just over 4
billion
one of the world's wealthiest countries
this is what Qatar spent building seven
new stadiums and rebuilding another
along with an entire metro Network it
forked out even more on skyscrapers
hotels highways universities museums and
a port
the country's been transformed literally
from the outside at least David could
that massive investment backfire on the
Emirate considering all the controversy
it's kicked off
yeah I think again they would argue that
um a lot of that spending is
infrastructure spending as you say
they've built a new Port they've built a
Metro System they've built other as you
say hotels
um and and a lot of infrastructure
um so they would say that that's General
building of the country perhaps it's
been accelerated by the fact that the
World Cup was happening but where I
think there's no doubt at all is that
they just weren't equipped like a
country such as Germany uh to host a
World Cup in the sense of having
stadiums they only had one stadium and
even that had to be uh quite
substantially
refurbished or re-refigured reconfigured
and then they've built seven you know as
we're seeing in our television screens
superb new brand new modern stadiums and
it's very very hard to see any sort of
after you
any sort of Legacy for those stadiums in
Qatar which is such a small country
there were some promises when they bid
for the World Cup when they got the vote
in 2010 that they were going to
dismantle some of the stadiums and and
build them in other countries that could
need them but I don't actually think we
know what is going to happen to the
stadiums but I think on The Wider
implication of your question will it
backfire because of the controversy it's
very very interesting to see now that
the tournament has started the action
starts the fans are in the stadiums the
broadcasters are all there the stadiums
look fantastic all lit up broadcast
around the world I think Qatar is this
is what they've been building up to this
is what they've spent the money for this
is what they've survived and sustained
all the controversy for because they
want to be able to project these images
of this is the country that has brought
all these people together over an
incredible event that you know people
love around the world the World Cup and
have come to Qatar and they want to show
that they've organized it really well
that the stadiums are incredible and
this is part of their National
projection their strategy for projecting
their country around the world
and it's Western allies are also keen on
putting a positive spin on this world
cup because of their relations with
Qatar they're strengthening their
alliances right now to cover their
energy needs amid the crunch created by
Russia uh what what do you think about
how Western nations are responding to
this world cup
I think that's a very good question and
I think that there this that does lead
us into this Tangled contradictory
um attitude that there is to it so I
think in the commentary
um there is so much uh criticism
um of Qatar of its treatment of uh the
migrant workers and quite rightly the
human rights groups have absolutely
um campaigned for better conditions uh
against
um elements of the working practices
that are abusive
um but at the same time and also lgbtq
plus rights and so on and other issues
of free speech obviously Qatar isn't a
democracy just like the other countries
in the Gulf but at the same time at
exactly the same time
um these countries are huge investors uh
in Europe I mean they're huge investors
in uh in the UK uh obviously
um the ruler one of the ruling family of
of Abu Dhabi owns Manchester City
Football Club uh a Saudi Arabian
Sovereign wealth fund owns Newcastle
United Football Club now they own huge
uh real estate in London uh and
elsewhere in in the UK and
um Qatar itself has signed a 10 billion
pound investment deal I think this year
or last year and the British government
is continually looking to the gulf for
investment particularly post-brexit so I
think the qataris at times uh find
themselves a bit baffled by quite how
much Western and European governments
are falling over themselves uh to
ingratiate themselves with their country
while at the same time there's so much
media criticism of our of the country
itself and conditions within it
and then there's a big commercial aspect
that's involved one of the major
sponsors of Germany's World Cup squad in
Qatar has ended its partnership with the
German Football Association major German
supermarket chain Rivas says it made the
decision because the dfb capitulated to
FIFA's threats to punish teams wearing
the one love armband in protest against
qatar's laws against homosexuality
captains of several European teams had
planned to wear it but backed down
David how dire is it when sponsors start
pulling out
yeah I mean it's very rare that sponsors
pull out and you know sponsors put up
with an awful awful lot uh sponsors are
concerned with their own brand image
um and they get huge brand uh exposure
and benefit from associating themselves
with football and I think usually uh a
criticism can go the other way which is
that football is used to launder the
images of the sponsors rather than that
the sponsors are concerned that their
image is going to be solid by its
association with football I think the
armband and the rainbow Flags yeah these
are really unfortunate uh upsetting
um things that have happened because we
can all see that the armband and the
rainbow that it's there to show
solidarity with lgbtq plus people but
also human Freedom the freedom to
express yourself
um it's a bit of a perennial issue
because FIFA takes the position and it's
not alone as a governing body of
football and of sport that it tries to
keep what it considers to be politics
and I know you could argue that that is
not a political gesture at all I'm not
really defending what FIFA have said I'm
just trying to explain that I think I
think that the background to this and
it's a very very long-standing position
is that if they start to allow
um the actual game itself on the pitch
to be used for political gesture
political demonstration then where would
it end and some of the causes that some
people or some players or some teams
might want to espouse might be causes
that we would find actually repugnant so
they try to keep it as a neutral space
and we've had examples in British
football where players have wanted to
show solidarity with different causes
that most people would absolutely
support and they've been disciplined for
it but it but it's always really
unattractive when it happens
what about when the hordes of fans who
are expected don't turn up or turn on
their Tellies I know a lot of people
boycotting the event Germany's World Cup
winner Philip lamb said he wouldn't go
well I think I mean I just don't feel
that that's been a widespread reaction
at all uh obviously there's not a single
team that has boycotted and that's when
it really has an impact and I think I
think that the figures are that 97 of
the seats are full and 97 of the tickets
have been bought
so for all the controversies and for all
the criticism
the put the whole point of why Qatar and
other countries want to host a World Cup
it is precisely because it is such a
loved and special event
that it would take something absolutely
uh huge and obviously bigger than the
criticism that had been of Qatar for a
boycott to happen and for supporters in
large numbers not to want to be there
and I think that the perspective that I
feel we should put on this as well
is that the World Cup the last World Cup
was held in Russia in 2018. Vladimir
Putin had already shown his true colors
he'd already annexed Crimea he'd already
been oppressive uh in the Dom bass I
think the world already knew exactly who
he was and yet there really wasn't
anywhere near as much controversy there
it wasn't didn't face as many
accusations of sports washing as this
has but I think when we look back now
and see how much it puffed up Vladimir
Putin
um and and just four years later he's
waging this horrific war against his
neighbor Ukraine I think we can see that
that was a massive Sports washing event
um and not
um just to boost the image of the
country but uh of you know a ruler of a
country who really did does have
murderous intent towards his neighbors
David apart from Sports watching this
world cup was built as environmentally
sustainable despite having to air
condition the stadiums I know a lot of
high tech and low energy solutions were
found but this was also meant to be a
compact event the stadiums aren't too
far apart but tens of thousands of
foreign fans are using shuttle flights
between Dubai and Doha due to a lack of
accommodation High hotel prices and
alcohol limits how would you judge the
green washing going on
uh
maybe I'm going to give a surprising uh
answer that might seem a bit tame but I
just think that that's a symptom of the
World At Large not grappling with the
climate crisis it is hard for me to
single out this event I mean every mega
event uh was the Olympics in London in
2012 was that environmentally friendly
or did it involve a lot of travel and
construction that wasn't really
necessary is the world just carrying on
hosting events do we all of us not want
to give up our way of life that was
forged in a time when climate crisis
wasn't as much of an issue so look it's
not at all surprising is it that the
hosting of a World Cup is not the most
environmentally friendly activity
um that we could be involved with and um
you know I think any real Promises to
the country were never really going to
be
um you know fully realized
well it'd be nice to see future World
Cups perhaps make more of an effort but
David uh let me also bring up something
you brought up earlier what happens once
the World Cup is over are these wise
Investments Sports tournaments are
notorious for creating white elephants
Dan Plumley specializes in sports
finance and he points out that other
more established footballing Nations
then Qatar had that problem too
issues with Brazil and South Africa so
it is a risk and it's always a risk with
any major sporting event I think some of
the things that Qatar have tried to do
are trying to be a little bit Innovative
so that you know there's a stadium
that's built from shipping containers
that can be taken down and then
reconstructed elsewhere but you always
run the risk with a major sporting
tournament that your stadiums are left
unused when everyone's gone home and and
I think that will still be a risk for
Qatar especially given the domestic
League system is not as advanced as
other countries yet so yeah it will be a
problem and but it's a problem with
every sporting event as well
so lastly David once the big event is
over what sort of country will the
people of Qatar be left with do you
think
well
Qatar won the right to host the World
Cup in 2010 12 years ago so we've all
had a lot of time to think about what is
this really for and what are they really
after and I think talking to people and
covering it myself I've come to the view
that
for the for this country hosting the
World Cup is part of a project for
National projection National the
building of the country itself on the
global stage and I think there's a very
small country
um population wise
um that's run by an emir a ruler and I
think that the emirs
um
Legacy that he is looking for his for
Qatar to be much better known on the
world stage and to have hosted an event
that's brought people together
successfully and he has been prepared or
they have been prepared to sustain all
the criticism and all the expense and
they they're clearly prepared to sustain
a number of stadiums that we cannot see
how they can have any real after use
um so I don't think it's that kind of
Legacy in the normal way that in in
Britain or in Germany people would be
very very critical of white elephants of
stadiums that didn't have an after use I
think that that's built into the budget
um and what the budget is paying for is
the projection of Qatar on the world
stage
we're going into extra time David so
we'll have to leave it there
investigations correspondent at the
guardian David Khan thanks for pitching
in and from DW business I'm Ben fazulin
whether or not you're watching this
world cup do take care bye-bye
thank you foreign